[ Music ]
[ Applause ]
>> Mr. President, as Faculty
Marshal, I have the honor
to declare the 118th
Commencement
of Carnegie Mellon University
as authorized by the Board
of Trustees to be in session.
[ Applause ]
[ Music ]
Please rise for the singing
of the National Anthem
by the Vocal Performance
Class of 2015.
[ Cheers ]
[ Silence ]
>> [Singing Together]
Oh, say can you see
by the dawn's early light,
what so proudly we hailed
at the twilight's last gleaming?
Whose broad stripes
and bright stars
through the perilous fight?
O'er the ramparts we watched
were so gallantly streaming.
And the rocket's red glare,
the bombs bursting in air,
gave proof through the night
that our flag was still there.
Oh, say does that star
spangled banner yet wave.
O'er the land of the free.
Of the free.
And the home of the,
of the, brave.
Of the brave.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Good morning.
We gather here in a
wonderfully diverse place.
Diverse in its fields of
study, talents and abilities,
ethnicities, and places
that we call home.
In light of respect for others
and with acknowledgement
of our differences, I invite you
to join with me if you are able
and so choose as we pray for
this day and the class of 2015.
Almighty God, we
gather this morning
to celebrate the diligent
work and incredible efforts
of this Carnegie Mellon
University Class of 2015.
We celebrate those who have
fulfilled the requirements
and effort to earn bachelors,
masters, and doctoral degrees.
We pause for a moment to
thank those who have helped us
and these students
achieve this day.
The parents, the
family, friends,
teachers, and professors.
And all others who have
been a wonderful support
to these students.
Thank you for the vision
and direction of those
who have helped make
Carnegie Mellon
into the school that
it is today.
We are grateful for the
professors and teachers
and staff and administration
and alumni of this university
who continue to carry
out that vision
of meeting the changing needs
of society in the greater world.
Continue to teach these
students and us as well to look
with compassion on
others both near and far,
take away any arrogance and
hatred that may influence us.
Give us the grace and the
ability to love our neighbors
and to seek peace in
all areas of life.
Bless these students as
they enter the next stages
of their lives.
Be with them as they take steps
into the known and the unknown.
May all that they
do and the decisions
that they make honor
you and the tradition
of Carnegie Mellon University.
May these graduates bless others
as they continue to create
and disseminate knowledge
and art, continue to serve
through their problem
solving and leadership skills
and respect for others.
Continue to develop their
minds and abilities and dreams
to enhance society in
meaningful and sustainable ways.
Bless also the rest of the world
that we may learn
to love like you.
Be with us this day and let
these students bring you glory.
Our hearts is in the work.
Amen.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Good morning ladies
and gentlemen.
On behalf of the Board of
Trustees, let me welcome you
to the 118th Commencement of
Carnegie Mellon University.
My name is Ray Lane.
It's my honor and pleasure
to serve as Board Chairman.
To all the students who are
graduating today, let me begin
by congratulating all of
you on your achievement.
This degree represents years of
hard work and self-discipline,
discovery, and difficult
problem solving.
The Carnegie Mellon
degree is a sign
that you've surpassed a high
standard of accomplishment
in science, art, and ideas,
and that you are ready
to use this knowledge
in your lives
and your future professions.
Let me congratulate you and all
of us congratulate
you on this day.
[ Applause ]
Congratulations too to friends
and family members, mentors,
faculty members, and
staff who also take pride
at what these graduates
have accomplished.
Graduation from a demanding
academic institution
like Carnegie Mellon
is a team effort.
These students couldn't
have done it without you.
I invite the graduates
to stand, turn around,
and join me in thanking
your support team
with a round of applause.
Please.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
With this at our 118th
Commencement, our faculty
and students from Carnegie
Mellon's other locations
around the world.
Silicon Valley, California
where it's only 8:30 a.m.
Education City in Doha,
Qatar where's it's
6:30 p.m. Kogali,
Rwanda where it's 5:30 p.m.
And the prize goes to Adelaide,
Australia [cheering] where
it's 1:00 a.m. tomorrow.
We're delighted to have
you all with us today
and tomorrow [laughter].
As graduates of Carnegie
Mellon, you are ambassadors
for what you have come to know
as a distinctive university.
It was at this university
you gained solid ground
in your major field of study.
It was here that
you collaborated
with people whose
backgrounds were very different
from your own.
And it was here that
you discovered new ideas
about the world and new
aspects of yourself.
The Board of Trustees believes
it is our job to affirm
and maintain the values
that underpin this distinctive
approach to higher education.
I will tell you that
no university
on the planet has a more engaged
and caring Board of Trustees.
Many members of the
Board are here with me
on the platform this morning.
I'd like them all to
stand to be recognized.
Please, Board.
[ Applause ]
Great. Great bunch of people.
This year, Carnegie Mellon has
added to its impressive momentum
with a number of new
initiatives that are combining
or contributing to the growth
of knowledge in the world.
We are moving forward rapidly
on ambitious research programs
and partnerships in areas
ranging from data science,
energy, the workings
of the brain,
and even the science
of learning itself.
The campus footprint
is growing with plans
for spectacular new
spaces designed
to make CMU a standard setter
for 21st century
higher education.
A lot of emphasis is being
placed on collaboration
across fields of expertise,
creative problem
solving, and innovation.
Behind all this growth an
expansion is our dynamic
President who joined the
University just two short years
ago from the National
Science Foundation
and who has already
made a tremendous impact
on our institution
and in our future.
It's my privilege to
introduce the ninth President
of Carnegie Mellon
University, Dr. Subra Suresh.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Ray.
Good morning everyone.
>> [Crowd Yelling] Good morning.
>> That's more like
it [laughter].
From this vantage point, it's
an extraordinarily looking
group [laughter].
Let me start by expressing my
profound appreciation and thanks
to Ray Lane for his
extraordinary service
as Chairman of the
Board of Trustees
of Carnegie Mellon University
for the past six years.
As you know, Ray's term
will come to an end
at the end of next month.
And I'm extraordinarily
grateful to him for his vision,
for his energy, for his
support, and his leadership.
Let's give him a
round of applause
to show our appreciation.
[ Applause ]
Mr. Jim Brewer will join
us at the new Chairman
of the Board effective July 1.
Jim is well known in so many
different circles including
in the Pittsburg area, where
he is a household name.
Let's give a round of
applause to Mr. Jim Brewer.
[ Applause ]
I would also like to add
my thanks to all members
of the Board of Trustees for
all the encouragement, support,
and leadership they
have provided in support
of the University's plans
over the past two years.
I would also like to
recognize the service
of some senior academic leaders.
Dr. John Lehoczky
generously stepped in to serve
as Interim Executive
Vice President this past
academic year.
And Dr. Nathan Urban
served as Interim Provost.
They both performed their roles
with deep dedication
to this University.
Both of them will be
returning to the faculty
at the end of next month.
John and Nathan, you
have our deepest respect,
gratitude, and appreciation.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
I would also like to
introduce Dr. Farnam Jahanian
who joined Carnegie
Mellon University last fall
as Vice President for Research,
and since then he's been named
the University's new Provost.
Farnam served for many years
on the faculty of Computer,
Science, and Engineering at
the University of Michigan.
He's a very successful
entrepreneur.
He also did national service
as the point person in charge
of Computer and Information
Science
and Engineering Directorate
for the National Science
Foundation prior to coming
to Carnegie Mellon University.
Dr. Jahanian is an outstanding
addition to our leadership team.
And I would like to welcome him
and look forward to continuing
to work with him in his new role
as Provost effective tomorrow.
[ Applause ]
I'm especially pleased today
to introduce a new tradition
into our commencement ceremonies
by officially acknowledging the
many alumni of Carnegie Mellon
who are here this morning.
Alumni may be recognized
by the blue stoles
they are wearing today.
Attending CMU is a tradition in
many families with grandparents,
parents, and children having
all attended the University.
I would like to ask all
members of such families
to stand and be recognized.
[ Applause ]
Now, I would like to invite
all alumni who are here
to stand and be recognized.
[ Applause ]
The alumni are well represented
in the University community
by the Carnegie Mellon
Alumni Association Board.
And it is now my pleasure
to introduce the President
of the Board, Rebecca Allison.
Becca earned two degrees
from Carnegie Mellon.
Her bachelor of humanities
and arts degree in 1996
and her masters of
public management
from Heinz College
in 2001 [cheering].
Becca lives in Phoenix,
Arizona and has spent her career
as a teacher and a university
student affairs professional.
I would now like to invite
Becca to say a few words.
[ Applause ]
>> Congratulations.
You are members of
a historic class.
Your Class of 2015
carries us over the mark
of 100,000 living
Carnegie Mellon Alumni.
[ Applause ]
I'm so honored to be here
to represent those alumni,
to welcome you and congratulate
you on this exciting day.
I love the energy that
exists on this campus.
There's almost a palpable
energy that crackles
in the air at all hours.
From those crisp, early fall
mornings racing across the cut
for buggy practice to the balmy
early spring evenings as people
and music spill out of CFA.
[ Cheers ]
This very same energy is
buzzing in the stadium today
with anticipation,
excitement, and pride.
You can feel it.
This energy is truly the
embodiment of the creativity,
innovation, and collaborative
spirit
that makes Carnegie
Mellon so unique.
In your busiest moments
when deadlines, due dates,
and finals were looming,
this energy sustained you.
I am confident that some of
this very energy carried you
through long nights in the
studio, lab, or library.
This intense energy
provided some warmth
in this winter months
as you braced yourself
against the blowing
wind to cross campus.
And in quiet, calm moments,
this is the rejuvenating
and refreshing energy that
told you that you were
in the right place
at the right time.
This is a special place
that you're leaving today.
Take it from me, that you
might not find this energy
in other places.
You'll look for it.
You'll seek it out.
But you may struggle to find it.
You may not realize how
much you'll long for it.
So, my advice to you
is harness it today.
Power up. What a
great day to do that.
Take it with you.
To infuse your new
workplaces and communities
and don't be surprised
when others recognize
this energy spark in you.
They will remark on it.
And they will be drawn to
you because you play to win.
Because you are the
diligent hard workers,
creative problem solvers,
and transformative leaders.
Harness it today while
you're still here.
Take this energy.
Carry it out into the world.
But here's the most beautiful
thing about this energy.
There's more waiting to
replenish and recharge it.
More amazing students
to follow after us.
And we can continue to
support them and ensure
that this energy can continue.
We can stay connected.
We can show pride and give
generously of our time
and our talent and our
treasure from years to come.
And eventually you'll miss it.
And you too will
need to tap back
into the energy source
so you come back.
And come back often.
Every time I return to campus
I'm reenergized, rejuvenated,
and reminded of why
I love this place.
And I promise this will
happen for you too.
Congratulations again.
[ Applause ]
I'd now like to introduce
Ian Glasner,
President of the Student Body.
Ian is graduating today with
a double major in electrical
and computer engineering
and business.
Please join me in welcoming him.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> Challenge.
If I could describe my Carnegie
Mellon experience in one word,
it would be challenge.
When I say challenge
I'm not simply talking
about the first computer
engineering exam I took
freshman year.
I am actually more so referring
to the subsequent phone call I
had to give my mom telling her
that I failed [laughter].
Things didn't exactly
start off as planned.
At the time, it felt
like Carnegie Mellon had
completely knocked me over.
But we've all learned
things here.
Like that a 0% chance of
rain really means the weather
forecaster is just hoping
it doesn't rain [laughter].
Those days usually
end with muddy shoes
and a soaking wet backpack.
Or that counting on a
Pittsburg bus to show
up on time is a great way to
be very, very late [laughter].
By knocking us over, Carnegie
Mellon has taught us how
to get back up.
And sometimes getting back up
involves drinking a Red Bull
or several cups of coffee in the
basement of Hunt Library alone
at 2:00 a.m. on a Saturday.
[ Cheers ]
We've all been there [laughter].
We've all learned.
I hope everyone brought an
umbrella today [laughter].
Everyone here today has a hit
a bump in the last four years.
And we've all gotten
back up after.
CMU has been a challenge, but
Class of 2015, we made it.
look around.
In less than 90 minutes,
we will all be graduates
of Carnegie Mellon University.
[ Cheers ]
Today, I would like to
share with you the first
of many incredible
achievements I hope
that our class will
have as alumni.
The Board of Trustees
challenged our class
to make a senior gift to campus.
Something similar to
the Class of 1987 room
in the Cohen University Center.
But it's easier said than done.
Asking college students to make
a donation is a tough sell.
Considering many of us
have borderline or not
so borderline negative
bank accounts [laughter].
The Class of 2013
gave at a rate of 6%.
And last year's seniors
gave at a rate of 15%.
Today, I'd like to announce
that more than 432 members
of our class contributed.
That's well over 30%.
[ Applause ]
It's more than double last year,
and it's an all-time
record for Carnegie Mellon.
[ Applause ]
In a few days, we will be
spread out across the country
and the world just like
we were four years ago.
Let's not make this the
last time we are all
in Pittsburg together.
Five, ten, fifty
years down the road,
remember Carnegie
Mellon University.
Remember where you learned how
to get back up and keep going.
So long Class of 2015.
May your futures be bright and
your hearts forever in the work
that we all did here together.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Ian.
And to the entire Class of 2015.
Congratulations, again.
Your determination, your
leadership, and your passion
to make a difference will
continue to set new records
for Carnegie Mellon
University no matter
where you reside in the future.
I am now pleased to introduce
another wonderful member
of your class, our student
speaker, Brooke Kuei.
[ Applause ]
She was selected to speak
today by a committee
of faculty, staff, and students.
Brooke is graduating
with a major in physics
and a minor professional
writing and intends
to pursue graduate study in
material science in the fall.
Brooke.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
>> When I pictured this
day four years ago,
this isn't what I thought
it would look like.
I thought I'd have it
all figured out by now.
I thought I'd know exactly
who I was, where I was going,
what direction my life
was going to take.
I thought I'd be so ready
to get out of here and dive
into a world where I make
big changes and be respected
and find success
around every corner.
But instead I'm scared.
I'm scared to leave this
Carnegie Mellon bubble
where I live with
my best friends,
where I know every shortcut
around campus like the back
of my hand, where the baristas
at the Starbucks on Forbes
and Craig scribble down my name
without even having to ask.
Maybe you're like me.
Maybe some part of you is scared
to leave the group me chats,
the annoying but familiar
beeping of the crosswalk
at Morewood, the tipsy journeys
down Buehler [phonetic],
the long lines at La Prima, the
concerts, carnival, the wine
and cheese nights
with red Solo cups.
I'm scared because for the past
four years my life has been
organized by Post
It notes and lists.
And I've diligently
crossed of the problem sets
and essays one by one.
We all complain about
how busy we were.
But we all know it was
actually a competition
of who was the busiest.
It wasn't easy.
I changed my minor four times.
I cried when I got my first C,
and I learned the limits
of sleep deprivation.
But we were always surrounded
by friends to talk to,
professors who inspired
us, in a community
that changed us the way a writer
revises a piece with love,
little by little,
until we slowly evolved
into different people.
But now we're here.
Now we're gently being
nudged out of the safe
and nurturing world where even
the weather was predictable.
Always rain [laughter].
The most frightening part about
the future is the uncertainty,
the worry that your dreams could
come crashing down on you just
as easily as they
could be achieved.
Whether you're starting
your first real job or going
to med school or grad school
or still trying to figure
out what you want, the future
may seen obscured by fog.
But the best part
about uncertainty is
that it's a equivalent
to possibility.
I've sometimes found
myself lamenting
over the things I
should have done.
I should have tried out for
dancer symposium instead
of chickening out
before auditions.
I should have taken
more philosophy classes.
I should have stayed
on the Frisbee team.
I should have said I
love you more often.
I should have gone out more
or gone out less [laughter].
Or learned how to
use that expensive
and hipster DSLR camera I
bought instead of relying solely
on my iPhone and
Instagram filters.
Should have said more to
that cute barista than,
"Can I have a tall
chai, please?"
But what am I saying [laughter]?
This is just the beginning.
It wasn't that long ago
when we went out to bars
for the first time and got our
Viking hats from Peter's Pub.
We've got our entire
lives ahead of us.
We've got all the time in the
world to do the things we want
to do, visit the
places we want to see,
become the people we've
always dreamed of becoming.
Who did you want to be
when you first got here?
When I first came
to Carnegie Mellon,
I wanted to be an
astrophysicist.
I wanted to look up at the night
sky and understand how we came
to be made of stardust
on this little planet
in this infinite universe.
I've discovered new
interests since then.
We all have.
But this amazement, this
wonderment of the world,
this sense of unbounded
possibility is something we must
seriously hold on to.
Throughout college, there
were plenty of times
when the workload was too much,
when the stress felt
overwhelming, when I wondered
if it was time to give up.
But the thing about
Carnegie Mellon is
that inspiration is
everywhere whether it's one
of those nerdy moments when you
learn something in one class
that clicks with
something from another class
or the pride you feel
when you see your friends
on stage during Greek sing or
culture night or the excitement
of reading about one of
your professor's research
in the news.
Something always keeps the
spark going pushing you
to keep growing oftentimes in
ways you weren't even expecting.
As Carnegie Mellon students,
we're sometimes so determined
and driven that when we
set goals for ourselves,
it's strange to see them
change or even fail.
I thought I was going
to be a physicist,
but now I'm becoming
an engineer.
My boyfriend is graduating as
an engineer, but now he wants
to be an entrepreneur.
Some of you were shy
when you first got here
and then became organization
leaders
and performers and mentors.
But that's why we don't
have just one school color.
We're plaid.
Carnegie Mellon taught us to get
out of the little box we
might have put ourselves
in to explore the possibilities,
to realize how many different
roles, we have the intellect
and the talent to
pursue in this world.
This is how Carnegie
Mellon has made be stronger,
how it's made you stronger,
and what we should all take
with us when we leave.
As we got through our
lives, let's continue
to keep our eyes wide
and our minds open
because although there are some
of you who took a perfect path,
that's not always the only path.
"Look at the moon.
Isn't it beautiful?"
my dad asked me during one
of my uninspired slumps.
"Yeah," I sniffled wondering
where he was going with this.
"But it's only ever a full moon
once a month," he continued.
"Most of the time it's just
a crescent or a half moon.
It's almost never a full moon,
yet it's always beautiful."
None of us are perfect
and few of us are sure
of exactly what we want yet.
We all break sometimes,
but we've also all made it
to this day, to the brink
of the rest of our lives.
And we're ready for it.
What we learned, enjoyed,
and discovered along this roller
coaster ride we call Carnegie
Mellon is how true
success, happiness,
and full potential are achieved.
We might be going our separate
ways after we graduate,
but we'll never forget the
time we spent here together,
growing together,
doing firsts together,
becoming great people together.
Let's take the strength
we've gained
through this transformation
and tackle the future
in front of us.
I want to thank my friends,
my family, and my professors
for always in believing in me.
Thank you for the late
night conversations,
for the unwavering support,
for the life philosophies.
Thank you for being the mirror
that reflects a better
version of myself back at me.
And on behalf of all
my fellow classmates,
thank you to everyone who
has helped us become Carnegie
Mellon graduates.
[ Cheers ]
When I pictured this
day four years ago,
this isn't what I thought
it would look like.
I thought I'd have it
all figured out by now.
I thought I'd know exactly
who I was, where I was going,
what direction my life
was going to take.
I thought I'd be so ready
to get out of here and dive
into a world where I make
big changes and be respected
and find success
around every corner.
But instead, I'm
even better off.
Sure, I don't know
exactly who I am yet.
But I do know that
I can be anyone.
You can be anyone.
So, Class of 2015, I challenge
you to embrace the uncertainty.
I challenge you to find
passion, to want something,
to walk to the sky for it.
I challenge you to let go
of the fears while
holding on to each other.
Let's take the knowledge, the
strength, and the confidence
that we've learned
here together,
and let's go make
this world ours.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Brooke.
It was wonderful and inspiring.
And now we come to
the presentation
of special doctors degrees
awarded to honor individuals
who have had extraordinary
impact in areas
that reflect Carnegie Mellon's
strengths in the arts, sciences,
scholarship, and society.
Recipients of these
honorary degrees have
in common a notable
record of accomplishments
in their chosen fields.
And they each have made,
in their own domains,
substantial contributions for
the advancement of knowledge,
the enrichment of the
arts and culture,
and to bettering the
well being of humanity.
Interim Provost Nathan Urban
will present each candidate
and cite the achievements
that merit this honor.
Then all candidates
will together
receive their degrees and
their doctoral hoods.
Please note that Judea Pearl
was to have received a doctor
of science and technology
degree today.
But he is unable to join
us due to a family illness.
Our thoughts go out to
Dr. Pearl and his family.
Carnegie Mellon plans to
confer the degree on Dr. Pearl
at a future commencement
ceremony.
Dr. Nathan Urban.
[ Silence ]
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you Dr. Suresh.
Will Joyce Kozloff
please come forward.
[ Silence ]
Joyce Kozloff, since
receiving your bachelor
of fine arts degree at
Carnegie Tech in 1964,
you have become one
of the foremost visual
artists of your generation.
In your work in diverse
media, you celebrate
and explore the meaning of
ornament, pattern, maps, charts,
and found materials from
diverse world cultures.
You have forged a
unique artistic language
that with beauty and power
expresses your own passionate
commitment to causes of
peace and human rights.
For your artistic
achievements and your vision
of social justice,
Carnegie Mellon is pleased
to award you the degree
of doctor of fine arts.
[ Applause ]
Will Kai-Fu Lee please
come forward?
[ Applause ]
Kai-Fu Lee, since your days as a
PhD student in computer science
at Carnegie Mellon,
you have taken
to heart the essence
of our university.
You have aimed to be the best in
the world at what you undertake.
You have applied this principle
to revolutionizing
speech recognition
to business leadership and
now to venture investing.
You have influenced
millions of people
around the world encouraging
them to follow their passions,
solve problems, and
work with others.
For your contributions
to technology, business
and humanity, Carnegie Mellon is
pleased to award you the doctor,
the degree of doctor
of business practice.
[ Applause ]
Will Stephen Schwartz
please come forward?
[ Cheers ]
It looks like you picked
a good one [laughter].
Stephen Schwartz, in your
long and amazing career,
you have a produced a one-man
renaissance of Broadway musicals
that thrill and delight
audiences all over the world.
From your scotch and soda days
at Carnegie Mellon [cheers]
to your hit musicals
like Pippin, Godspell,
and Wicked [cheers] to your
work in such animated films
as Pocahontas and Enchanted
[cheers], your music
and lyrics sparkle with
wit, warmth, and insight.
You bring magic shows and
miracles to life for all
of us challenging our minds
and lifting our spirits.
For your ongoing achievements
and creative contributions
to the American musical theater,
Carnegie Mellon is pleased
to award you the degree
of doctor of fine arts.
[ Applause ]
Will Carl Wieman
please come forward.
[ Applause ]
Carl Wieman, you shared the
Nobel Prize in Physics in 2001
for your path breaking
work on atomic physics.
But since that honor, you've
dedicated your intellect,
prestige, and energy to the
cause of better teaching.
You want nothing less than to
revolutionize the way science is
taught everywhere.
Using principles of learning
science and student engagement,
you are setting a high standard
for university science
instruction
that is helping more
students succeed
in these challenging
disciplines.
You have been a special
inspiration
to Carnegie Mellon's
Simon initiative
in technology enhanced learning,
and you are a valued member
of the Global Learning Council.
For your brilliant
achievement as a physicist
and for your impact
as an educator,
Carnegie Mellon is pleased to
award you a degree of doctor
of science and technology.
[ Applause ]
Will Alan Alda please
come forward?
[ Applause ]
Alan Alda, as actor, writer,
director, and science nerd,
you are a CMU kind of guy.
Your portrayal of Hawkeye Pierce
in the series MASH
defined an era
of American television comedy.
[ Applause ]
In your later acting
and directing career,
your own special brand of
dramatic genius shown through.
And in all your productions,
you always entertain,
sometimes provoke, and
frequently move audiences.
You love to learn new things.
And your skills as a
communicator have allowed you
to share your enthusiasm
for science and engineering
with worldwide television
audiences
where you clearly convey
your own underlying wonder
at the nature of
discovery itself.
For your achievement
of excellence
in these diverse fields,
Carnegie Mellon is pleased
to award you the degree
of doctor of fine arts.
[ Applause ]
>> Alan Alda, Joyce
Kozloff, Kai-Fu Lee,
Stephen Schwartz,
and Carl Wieman.
By virtue of the authority
granted to me by the Board
of Trustees, I hereby confer
these degrees upon you
with all the rights,
honors, privileges,
and responsibilities
pertaining thereto.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
This is what is so unique and
wonderful about Carnegie Mellon.
This eclectic group
of high achievers.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
It is now my great honor
to introduce our
commencement speaker today.
Although I was a fan of Alan
Alda the actor for a very,
very long time, I had the
pleasure of having a meeting
with him as a science
communicator just a few years
ago in Washington where
we hit it off right away.
Alan's quick wit, his deep
curiosity about science,
and his engaging energy
came through to everyone
who met him that day with me.
If any one embodies Carnegie
Mellon's blending of the arts
and sciences, it is
surely Alan Alda.
And I'm delighted to
welcome him to the lectern
as our keynote speaker today.
Alan?
[ Applause ]
>> All around the country
today, distinguished men
and women are looking
at graduates like you
from the heights
of our achievements
and spraying advice
at you [laughter].
It's an indignity you have
to suffer before they lift
the latch and release you
into the wild [laughter].
In settings like this today,
you're going to hear all
over the country many
of the same themes.
Be true to yourself.
Follow your passion.
You are the future.
Don't make a mess of the world
the way we did [laughter].
I know these words because I've
said many of them myself often.
And they're good ideas.
The only thing is they're
a little vague I think.
And every time I am tempted
to make a speech like that,
I wish instead I could just
give you a few good tips
on how just to get through life.
Like the Admiral last year who
gave one of these speeches.
His advice was so
concrete, so simple.
He said, "If you want
to change the world,
make your bed every day."
Isn't that wonderful [laughter]?
I love that.
I mean it's just,
it's utter simplicity.
I mean if you could start off
a day with a little discipline
like that, there's no telling
what you can accomplish
when the hard stuff
comes your way.
The problem is, I can't really
give you that advice myself
because I don't make my
bed every day [laughter].
I do. I unscramble the covers.
And I pull them up to the
pillow so it looks sort of neat.
But I don't make it,
you know, all so tight
that you could bounce a quarter
on it the way the
Admiral does [laughter].
I'm looking at your faces.
You're thinking, "Why are they
having this guy up here talking
about making his bed?"
[ Laughter ]
There's actually a reason
for why I'm saying this.
I think it's important
as you leave here today,
if you haven't already done
it, to start paying attention
to how your own particular
brain works.
You know, the Admiral likes
a hard discipline approach.
The experience of being tough.
He likes that.
And I'm sure a lot of you
benefit from that too.
But I'm a little more flexible.
I pull the covers up just
enough so the next time I look
at them it'll be a
little gift to myself,
and I'll get a little jolt
of some happiness
hormones when I look at it.
And that's good for me.
That's the way I like it.
The point is that there
is no good or bad way
to start the day I don't think.
But I think you can learn to get
the most out of your particular,
your own brain if you pay
attention to how it works.
I used to push my brain.
You know, sort of like the way a
jockey would whip a horse trying
to make it run faster
than it can run.
But now I'm more tolerant
of the way my brain works.
I'm easier on it.
I get it pointed in
a certain direction.
And it works in the
background in its own time
and when it's ready to come up
with the goods, it lets me know.
But the thing is, it takes time.
You know, I bring this
up because if I'm going
to pass anything on to you
today, it has to be real to me.
For instance, my grandson
Scott is graduating today,
and that's very real.
[ Cheers ]
That's real to me.
And so is the fact that
he'll be entering my field.
He's going to be facing
a lot of uncertainty.
But, you know, uncertainty
is not always a bad thing.
In fact, I kind of
welcome uncertainty.
I think instead of resisting
it, you can surf uncertainty.
You know, keep your balance.
Stay agile.
Expect the unexpected bumps.
It's harder to do
when uncertainty comes
at you like a tsunami.
But it's a good principle
to live by.
The thing is, it's not just
Scott who is going to be going
out facing uncertainty
in his chosen field.
Every one of you here today
is going to face uncertainty.
It's going to hit you.
You'll face it no
matter what you do.
And sometimes it will make
you rethink what you're doing.
And here's an interesting thing.
Uncertainty usually
comes from the outside.
But sometimes it can
come from your own heart.
If you suddenly are
up against a situation
where you remember what
your own principles are,
what your values are, sometimes
the choice can be difficult.
I'll give you an example.
My wife just wrote a book
about people who were brought
up in the Bronx [cheer].
The Bronx, right.
Good. Very good [laughter].
Excellent.
Read the book.
You'll love it [laughter].
So, I met one of the people in
the book that she interviewed.
And he told me such an
interesting, powerful story
about this thing I was just
talking about knowing you values
and coming up against them,
coming up against
something in your own heart.
He came from a working
class family.
And his father had lived
through the Depression.
And his father told him
constantly, "Be a plumber.
People will always
need plumbing."
But this was a very smart kid,
and he went to medical school.
And he was so smart that as a
young man, he invented a device
that would save lives.
And a medical company offered
him hundreds of millions
of dollars for the
patent to the device.
The only thing was,
they were going,
for some reason they were going
to hold it back from putting it
on the market for a whole year
before they started selling it.
Now, that meant that he
could either release it
to the public right away
and start saving lives
or he could take the hundreds
of millions and wait a year.
And his father, who had
lived through the Depression
and kept telling
him be a plumber,
his father said, "Don't do it.
Don't take the money."
He said, "Think of all
the people, the mothers
and children you will die during
that year while this company is
waiting to put it on the market.
Put it out there now."
And then every night
when he went to bed,
the father would say to him,
"When you wake up tomorrow
and you look in the mirror to
shave, don't look at yourself.
Don't think about
your own image.
Think about those mothers and
children who are going to die
if you wait for a year.
So, what do you think?
Did he take the money or did
he put it out on the market?
He had to make a decision.
It was a very tough decision.
Sometimes you have to
make really tough ones.
And they come at you
unexpectedly like that.
But you can certainly
surf uncertainty better.
You can find your balance better
if you know how to respond
to your own principles.
So, I'll tell you - I'll
tell you what he did.
He didn't take the money.
And decades later when he told
me the story he was really happy
about it because he did
what he thought was right.
It makes him feel
good to know that.
But here's the thing.
That was many years ago.
In those days we had time
to think things through.
We had time to consider
these things.
You don't have that
luxury so much anymore.
All of the sudden now things
are going really fast.
Let me give you an example
of how fast things are going.
I love this example.
A few years ago the Internet
was flooded with copies
of a graduation speech that
Kurt Vonnegut had given at MIT.
It spread across the country.
It spread all over the
Internet, all over the world.
And it did that in
just a few hours.
That's how fast it was.
I was quoted everywhere.
And I'd like to read
some of it to you.
I love it because it
gives very simple advice.
Clear cut, every day, how
to live your life advice.
He said, "Here's a few words
for the graduating class.
Wear sunscreen.
If I could offer you only
one tip for the future,
sunscreen would be it.
The long-term benefits of
sunscreen have been proven
by scientists, whereas the
rest of my advice has no basis,
more reliable than my
own meandering thoughts.
I will dispense this advice now.
Enjoy the power and
beauty of your youth.
Oh, never mind.
You will not understand
the power and beauty
of your youth until
they've faded.
But trust me, in 20 years you'll
look back at photos of yourself
and recall in a way you can't
grasp now how much possibility
lay before you and how
fabulous you really looked.
You are not as fat
as you imagined.
Sing. Don't be reckless
with other people's hearts.
Don't put up with people
who are reckless with yours.
Floss. Remember compliments
you receive.
Forget the insults.
If you succeed in doing
this, show me how.
Stretch. Get plenty of calcium.
Be kind to your knees.
You'll miss them
when they're gone.
Get to know your parents.
You never know when
they'll be gone for good.
Be nice to your siblings.
They're your best link to your
past and the people most likely
to stick with you in the future.
Don't expect anyone
else to support you.
Maybe you have a trust fund.
Maybe you'll have
a wealthy spouse.
But you never know when either
one might run out [laughter].
Be careful whose advice you buy.
Advice is a form of nostalgia.
Dispensing it is a way
of fishing the past
from the disposal,
wiping it off,
painting over the ugly
parts, and recycling it
for more than its worth.
But trust me on the sunscreen."
Now, the thing about
this charming piece
by Kurt Vonnegut is that it
wasn't written by Kurt Vonnegut.
It was written by a
newspaper columnist
in Chicago called Mary Schmich.
Some unknown person
had posted it
on the Internet saying it
was written by Kurt Vonnegut.
And it spread all
around the world in hours
with his name attached to it.
Schmich said it went to Italy
and France to Israel and Brazil,
to places I didn't
know had electricity.
And she said even
Mr. Vonnegut's wife,
the photographer Jill
Krementz received it,
emailed it to several friends,
and then asked her husband,
"Why didn't you tell me you
spoke at MIT [laughter]?"
And he said, "Because I didn't."
Somebody said it was the
most widely distributed piece
of email in the history
of the Internet.
But after only a few
hours of bouncing
around the world it was
identified as a hoax.
And in a flash, the Internet
was flooded with retractions.
By the end of one
extraordinary day, vast numbers
of people had accepted and
then rejected a worldwide hoax.
And that's what makes this
Internet event a great image
for the age we live in now.
There were probably
just as many lies going
around now as there ever were.
But these days they're
traveling at the speed of light.
And with the help of an engine
for repetition that works
on a scale unheard of in
human history, the lies stick.
People are still sending
around that talk saying it
was written by Kurt Vonnegut.
All right.
So, big deal you
may be thinking.
You may be thinking it's
just a few jokes about youth
and beauty and trivial things.
But think about it.
It could be selling
you anything.
It could be a cult religion that
could separate you from friends
and family or a quack medicine
that could leave you paralyzed
or bogus political information
that could decide and election.
Being able to know what's true
and what's a lie is a
lot harder to do now.
Harder than every before.
And so now more than
ever you need the wisdom
of a trusted partner or
a friend or a mentor,
somebody who can remind
you of what counts.
Now, more than ever, I think
you need to know who you are
and what you believe in.
And who you are is a
tough one because most
of us have many people
inside us.
But in your finer moments,
you aspire to things
that make sense even
while you're enjoying a
momentary distraction.
You know that down the road
something is going to come along
that is going to require skill,
ability, and you're going
to know you can't wing it.
So, you're going to
be prepared for it.
You're going to know that one
of the deepest pleasures comes
from knowing how to do
something that's hard well.
And you'll be prepared.
You'll take the time that
it takes to learn it.
And we have a challenge
about time now.
So, let yourself be all
the yous that you are,
but don't let them
crowd out the smart one.
And as for what you believe
in, values are really not
so much what you
say is what you do.
The more you bring
those two things
into line the easier it'll
be to get where you're going.
You know, you may say you
want to go to Chicago.
But it's going to
be hard to get there
if you keep buying
tickets to Las Vegas.
I think we don't realize
how important time is.
When we couldn't communicate
at the speed of light,
we didn't think about
it that much.
But things do take time
like the time it takes
for your brain to
work on a problem.
And chemical reactions
take time.
Mourning a loss takes time.
In fact, all the transitions
of our life take time.
Getting your brain or your
body in shape takes more
than a weekend no matter what
they tell you in the brochure.
It takes time for a
species to adapt to changes
in the environment that we
cause which makes us one
of the most dangerous
species that's ever lived.
We can make changes in
the environment so rapid
that nature doesn't have time to
replenish species that can live
in that changed environment.
And I don't want to kid you
into thinking I've got
this all worked out,
that I know how to do it.
I'm still working on it myself.
But this is what I aspire to.
So, this is real to me, and
I'm passing it on to you.
So, as you make the transition
from this page in your life
to the next chapter, I wish all
of you what I wish for Scott.
I wish you health, happiness,
resilience, love, laughter,
patience, cash [laughter],
strength, plenty of time,
and a friendly relationship
with your own brain.
And if all else fails, floss and
wear your sunscreen [laughter].
Thank you and good luck.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Alan, for
those wonderful remarks.
You've inspired and
enlightened us all.
At this point, I'm very pleased
to recognize our faculty.
A group of scholars, scientists,
artists, and above all teachers.
Every year esteemed
and dedicated faculty
members retire.
And it is my honor
now to recognize those
who are retiring this year.
Please stand as I
read your name.
Patricia Bellan-Gillen.
[ Cheers ]
Stubnitz Professor of Art
from the School of Art.
Al Blumstein, the J Erik
Johnson University Professor
of Urban Systems and Operations
Research of the Heinz College.
[ Applause ]
Edmond Clark, the Four
Systems University Professor
from the Department
of Computer Science.
[ Applause ]
Chris Hendrickson, Hamerschlag
University Professor of Civil
and Environmental Engineering.
[ Applause ]
Wojciech Maly, UA and Helen
Whittaker Professor the
Department of Electrical
and Computer Engineering.
[ Applause ]
Jack Mostow, Research Professor
of the Robotics Institute.
[ Applause ]
Charles Neuman, Professor,
the Department of Electrical
and Computer Engineering.
[ Applause ]
Joan Stein, Principal
Librarian for Assessment,
Marketing, and Training.
[ Applause ]
Don Sutton [cheers], Professor
of History and Anthropology
of the Department of History.
[ Applause ]
And Dick Tucker.
Dick is the Paul Mellon
University Professor
of Applied Linguistics of the
Department of Modern Languages.
[ Applause ]
Please join me in thanking all
of Carnegie Mellon's retiring
faculty for their commitment
and years of service
to the University.
[ Applause ]
We will now begin the
formal conferral of degrees
on all students who have duly
completed the requirements
of their programs to the
Satisfaction and approval
of their faculty members.
We will ask the degree
candidates from each college
to stand and be recognized
in turn
as you are introduced
by your Dean.
When all schools and
colleges have been recognized,
the President will ask
students to stand again,
and he will formerly
confer your degrees.
Got that [laughter]?
OK. OK. The commencement program
gives each students degree
in areas of study, which will
be called out and celebrated
at the department
diploma ceremonies.
I encourage families
and friends to look
and listen beyond just
your own graduate's listing
to get a sense of the unique,
educational environment
at Carnegie Mellon and also
to appreciate the many areas
of interest and expertise
in this graduating class.
I want to begin by
acknowledging the achievements
of this year's group of
doctor degree candidates.
These outstanding scholars
received their academic hoods
at a special ceremony
last night.
In earning their doctorates,
they have made a commitment
to a life of scholarly pursuits
and reaffirmed the importance
and prominence of
Carnegie Mellon as one
of the nation's premiere
research universities.
I would invite the
doctor degree candidates
to please rise and
be recognized.
[ Applause ]
You can be seated.
In addition, we are
pleased today
to also officially
confer bachelors degrees
to students graduating
from Carnegie Mellon
University Qatar.
These students earn degrees
from the Dietrich College,
the Mellon College of Science,
the School of Computer Science,
and the Tepper School
of Business.
At this time, I want
to recognize the Dean
of Carnegie Mellon
University Qatar, Ilker Baybars
who will continue
to do, who continues
to do an outstanding job
leading the campus in Doha.
Dean Baybars, please
stand and be recognized.
[ Applause ]
For the conferral of degrees
at the university level,
when we call for degree
candidates to stand,
we will be calling for the
broad categories of bachelors,
masters, and doctoral
level candidates.
I will now call the dean
of each school or college
to present its candidates
for degrees.
All degrees will be conferred
upon students as a group
after all schools or
colleges have been presented.
To begin, I want to
recognize James Garrett,
Dean of the College
of Engineering.
[ Applause ]
>> Will all of the
candidates from the College
of Engineering please rise.
[ Cheers ]
Mr. Provost, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the bachelors, masters,
and doctoral candidates from
the College of Engineering.
[ Applause ]
Will the new College
of Engineering graduates
please be seated.
>> I now recognize the
Dean of the College
of Fine Arts, Dan Martin.
[ Applause ]
>> Will all of the
candidates from the College
of Fine Arts please rise.
[ Cheers ]
Mr. Provost, by the
recommendation of the faculty,
I present, I'm proud to
present the bachelors, masters,
and doctoral candidates from
the College of Fine Arts.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
Please be seated.
Thank you.
>> I will now recognize the
Dean of the Dietrich College
of Humanities and Social
Sciences, Richard Scheines.
[ Cheers ]
Dr. Scheines is completing
his first year as dean.
In that time he has
contributed much to the program,
to the college, and
contributing to the leadership
of the University as a whole.
>> Will the candidates from the
Dietrich College of Humanities
and Social Sciences please rise.
[ Cheers ]
Mr. Provost, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of presenting
the bachelors, masters,
and doctoral degree candidates
from the Dietrich College
of Humanities and
Social Sciences.
[ Applause ]
Well done.
Please be seated.
>> I now recognize the Dean
of the Heinz College
Ramayya Krishnan.
[ Cheers ]
>> Will all the candidates from
the Heinz College please rise.
[ Cheers ]
Mr. Provost, upon the
recommendation of our faculty,
we have the honor of
presenting the masters
and doctoral degree candidates
from the Heinz College.
[ Applause ]
Will the new Heinz College
graduates please be seated.
>> I now recognize the
Dean of the Mellon College
of Science Fred Gilman.
[ Applause ]
>> Will all the candidates
from the Mellon College
of Science please rise.
[ Applause ]
Mr. Provost, on the
recommendation
of our distinguished faculty,
I have the pleasure and honor
of presenting the
bachelors, masters,
and doctoral degree candidates
from the Mellon College
of Science.
[ Applause ]
Will the Mellon College
of Science graduates
please be seated [laughter].
>> I now call on the
Dean of the School
of Computer Science,
Andrew Moore.
[ Cheers ]
Dean Moore returned to
Carnegie Mellon this year
to lead the School
of Computer Science
after a successful tenure at
Google's Pittsburg office.
We are delighted
to welcome him back
to CMU as a dean.
>> Will all the candidates
from the School
of Computer Science please rise.
[ Applause ]
Mr. Provost, upon
the recommendation
of the distinguished faculty of
the School of Computer Science,
I would ask for conference of
the degrees for the masters,
bachelors, and doctoral
candidates.
[ Applause ]
Will the graduates of the School
of Computer Science
please sit down.
>> I now call on the
Dean of the Tepper School
of Business Robert Dammon.
[ Cheers ]
>> Will all the candidates
from the Tepper School
of Business please rise.
[ Cheers ]
Mr. President, upon
the recommendation
of our distinguished
faculty, I have the honor
of presenting the
bachelors, masters,
and doctoral degree candidates
from Tepper School of Business.
[ Applause ]
Will the new Tepper School
graduates please be seated.
>> Carnegie Mellon is
justifiable well known
for its success
in interdisciplinary
research and education.
This has given rise to several
University-wide intercollege
and joint degree programs.
I'd now like to present
the candidates for degrees
from these special programs.
Will all of the bachelors,
masters, and doctoral candidates
in the interdisciplinary
programs please rise.
[ Applause ]
Mr. President, upon
recommendation of our faculty,
I have the honor of
presenting these candidates
from our University-wide
intercollege
and joint degree programs.
[ Applause ]
>> Thank you, Nathan.
By virtue of the authority
granted to me by the Board
of Trustees, I hereby confer
these degrees upon these
candidates with all the
rights, honors, privileges,
and responsibilities
pertaining thereto.
I'm pleased to join the
deans and the faculty
of the entire University
in congratulating you.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
I will now officially welcome
you as the newest of more
than 100,000 global alumni of
Carnegie Mellon University.
[ Applause ]
You have much to be proud of.
Today is as much about looking
ahead as it is looking back.
As you anticipate
your next endeavor,
I would like to encourage you to
do so confident in the knowledge
that CMU has equipped you
for whatever comes next.
And in ways that are
totally unpredictable today
that you might not
even recognize.
You already know that
you've been deeply educated
in your major field of study.
Employers around the
world tell us consistently
that CMU graduates are
exceptionally well prepared
to contribute to their
organizations from Day 1.
You know how to conceptualize
a complex problem,
frame a novel interpretation,
how extraordinary
artistic talent,
and work effectively on a team.
The content knowledge you
acquired here will almost
certainly require renewal.
But the conceptual foundations
you have established will allow
you to continue to learn over
the course of your lives.
But I want to suggest that you
have also been learning other
lessons both inside and
outside the formal curriculum.
You've been immersed in
an environment that drives
on innovation, collaboration,
collegiality,
and a creative response
to the unexpected.
You learn to invent new
things, to work with others
on a club activity, a buggy
team on a community project.
You learn to communicate
with people who are different
in background and
style of working.
These are critical skills
for the future and the world
where the momentum of
innovation will only accelerate.
None of us can predict how
these threads will intertwine
through our lives.
Small moments can circle
back in our lives in ways
that are totally unforeseen.
You cannot imagine them today.
Let me give you a few examples.
On the 24th of August, 1977,
I took my maiden flight,
traveled over several thousand
miles and landed in Ames,
Iowa for a graduate study
in mechanical engineering
at Iowa State University.
A step that will
permanently force me to speak
with an Iowa accent [laughter].
I turned on my, within a few
days of arriving I turned
on my first American TV.
Most of you will not
know what it was like.
Small, vacuum tube,
black and white.
And what was on?
The very first image I saw
on my first American television
was the image of Hawkeye Pierce
from the sitcom MASH
starring Alan Alda.
At that moment, I would
never, ever have believed
that I would meet this
world famous actor
or have the opportunity to
discuss science literacy
with him at the National
Science Foundation,
let alone award him an
honorary degree right here
at Carnegie Mellon University.
[ Applause ]
Traveling to Iowa
State University
for me was only possible because
I received a travel grant
from a trust established
by the Indian major
industrial conglomerate Tata.
Two years ago, on
this very stage,
Mr. Ratan Tata received
an honorary degree,
and I met him here at
Carnegie Mellon University.
How could I have
ever known in 1977
that this would be
the path I would take.
None of us can predict
the trajectory
of our lives and careers.
Carl Wieman, who grew
up in rural Oregon,
who received an honorary degree
today, struggled to get even
to a library close to
the house that he lived
in which was a hundred
miles away.
More than 50 of those miles
were on unpaved roads.
Winning a Nobel Prize in Physics
was not even in his universe
of imagined possibilities.
Yet he did win a
Nobel Prize in 2001
for his pioneering
discoveries related
to the Bose Einstein condensate.
[ Applause ]
Carl beautifully complements
that profound accomplishment
with the deep empathy
is has today
for students struggling
to learn science.
In 1967, right here on
our own campus, a young,
undergraduate junior
wrote a musical written
by a fellow student,
wrote a musical for Scotch
and Soda performed
by fellow students.
That was Stephen Schwartz.
The show he called Pippin
became a major sensation
and remains one of the
biggest Broadway hits
of our time nearly 50 years
after its CMU premiere.
[ Applause ]
I could tell similar
stories about many
of the people sitting
behind me on the stage.
Many of the people on whom we
have bestowed honorary degrees.
Life did not unfold
according to any precise plan.
But these success stories are
built up on the ability to bring
to each new circumstance one's
individual strengths, purpose,
passion, and principles.
These are innovators able
to pivot, [inaudible],
and adopt the unexpected.
And they respond with aspects
from their hearts
as from their heads.
This will be true
in your lives too.
As the strengths of your
lives unfold and intertwine.
Things will arise
that you did not
and could not predict
or plan for.
That's OK.
Your generation has lived
with almost non-stop change
for your entire lives.
You simply expect that
new ideas, new tools,
and new devices will
emerge continually.
And that long established
truths and practices could be
and would be discarded.
You are innovators on a scale
unprecedented in human history.
This is just normal
life for you.
This explosion of knowledge
has come about at least in part
because many disciplines are
coming together more readily
than ever before.
Abetted by technologies of
discovery and new sources
of data, the confluence of
biology, behavioral sciences,
and computation, [inaudible]
advances in brain sites.
Progress in energy
and sustainability
requires engineers
of every sort plus economists,
architects, designers,
policy analysts, historians,
and computer scientists.
The fine and performing arts are
continually engaged with science
and technology both as new
expressive media and as sources
of artistic themes and concerns.
No matter what your field
is, you have already come
to appreciate the creative
clash of disciplines.
That is something that Carnegie
Mellon is very well known for.
As we look at the 21st century
ahead of you, ahead of all
of us, one of the most
defining characteristics
of the 21st century is the way
in which technology
impacts human condition.
No other university can
prepare its graduates
at the intersections of
technology and human condition
as Carnegie Mellon can.
[ Applause ]
Alan Alda has the rare and
probably even unique distinction
of being named for an Oscar,
an Emmy, and a Tony as well
as a bestselling book
all in the same year.
An incredible achievement.
But with the expansion and
intricate connection of areas
of inquiry, new and even
more amazing possibilities
will emerge.
Some day we could
have the possibility
that there will be somebody
who is nominated for an Oscar,
an Emmy, a Tony, the
bestselling book, a Turing Award
in computer science,
and a Nobel Prize all
in the same year [laughter].
And that's likely to
happen at Carnegie Mellon.
[ Applause ]
The ability to respond
productively
to unanticipated outcomes, to
be open to innovative ideas,
and to grow your capacity to
work across diverse fields
with diverse others while
keeping your hearts in the work
and having your work
come from your heart.
And connecting to the work
that is in your hearts.
These brought you here today.
They will be even more
important for your future.
And I'm very confident that
you are perfectly ready today.
And we, your families, your
professors, your mentors,
and Carnegie Mellon University,
look forward to seeing you,
seeing the impact of the Class
of 2015 around the world.
We want to support and celebrate
you every step of your way.
So, my final request to you
today is to stay in touch.
Be connected with Carnegie
Mellon University forever.
Stay involved.
Take advantage of the
CMU alumni network.
Connect to one another.
If the 115-year history
of Carnegie Mellon
University is any indication,
those of you sitting here
receiving your degrees today
will be movers, shakers,
leaders, innovators,
extraordinary artists,
humanists,
social scientists, designers.
So, as is a piece of
practical advice, when you look
to the person sitting in
front of you, next to you,
or behind you, remember
20-30 years
from now they'll be leaders.
They'll have a lot of resources.
Some of them may be your boss.
Be nice to them.
It will come in handy.
Keep in touch with them.
Together with them, you
will change the world.
My warmest congratulations
and best wishes
to each and every one of you.
Congratulations.
[ Applause ]
We will conclude
today's ceremony
by singing the Alma Mater by the
Vocal Performance Class of 2015.
We invite you to please
rise and sing along.
The words to Alma Mater can
be found in your program.
Also, please remain standing at
the conclusion of the Alma Mater
for the recession of graduates.
Congratulations.
[ Silence ]
[ Music ]
>> [Singing] Here where spangled
wildernesses robed the fountains
of the west.
Where the savage strife
and stresses brought the
settlers' crimson quest.
Land of legend, glory, graces.
Gypsy tide and toiling shore.
'Mid they hilltops, Alma Mater.
Stands enthroned forever more.
All hail Carnegie, Alma Mater.
[ Applause ]
[ Silence ]
[ Music ]